I don't want the answer just yet I
wonder if someone can help me with a
line of working for each of these let's
do the first one first what line of work
you should write down
I can't pause for a second why is it
cause how did you know it was cause I
can't very good you've got this angle
here right so this is right next to you
and this is the hypotenuse very good
yeah it's opposite the right angle
remember you can either go with the
longest side or you look for the right
angle you can't talk about the longest
side one yeah okay so like you said um
cos 13 degrees equals okay Jason on my
upon these many times what do I do it is
okay this X is almost it's only one step
for being by itself so I'm gonna
multiply both sides by 15 and your
calculated then should tell you can I
get the rounded off fourteen point six
okay so it's easy to like what goes
where and how do I use them so that's
why I go working this so important
please please do not just rely on your
calculator I think this is what I'm
gonna do just right now you can see it
didn't take us long me though all right
again the first line of working for this
next one could be do sign sign again I
would I won't write at this time but um
how did you know it was so I can tell to
tell us it cause uh
Lapras it on hypotenuse okay
so therefore when I say sine theta da
know what the angle is but I'm gonna
have the two point four on the 4.3
instead okay okay no excuse me at this
point this is when you learn our way I'm
gonna have to press shift because I want
to get rid of sign on the left-hand side
do you see that so you can write theta
equals maybe this is what you're gonna
punch into your calculator right theta
equals and remember this is the way we
say this is sine inverse and then you've
got that number you want to put in
so again can someone give me the rounded
off on top